well you know I hope America always
remains the most powerful nation on
earth and I would not want to see a
world where where Russia once again or
China were in superpower status because
I believe that that a strong America is
the best allied peace has ever known
that you want to see an American
military strength that that that leaves
without question the fact that if you
attack America that you're going to get
a lot more coming back at you than you
ever launched I think you want to see
America as a powerful economy because
our economy of course fuels are our
military but also fuels that the the
living standards of the people in our
country and you want to see strong
families and and fundamentally a
nation's ability to remain the world's
leader and have its greatness not taken
for granted flows from families good
families with good values with moms and
dads and aunts and uncles and
grandparents that care for their
children with good schools with good
health care with good jobs frankly
that's why I'm running is to strengthen
America and make sure that America
remains the most powerful the most
promising nation on earth and that
America and the peace and prosperity
that it is brought to so many people is
showered on my kids and grandkids like
yours and everybody else's
you